YUFENG GUO: Pandas are
majestic eaters of bamboo,
and very good at sleeping
for long periods of time.
But they also have
a secret power--
chomping down on
large data sets.
Today we'll introduce one of the
most powerful and popular tools
in data wrangling, and
it's called Pandas.
When you think of
data science, pandas
is probably not the first
thing that comes to mind.
These black and white bears
spend most of their time
eating bamboo and sleeping,
not doing data science.
But today, we'll use Pandas
to manipulate our data sets
and set it up for
machine learning.
I can't do the entire library
justice in just one video,
but hopefully this overview
will help you get going.
And I'll leave it to you to
explore the fascinating world
of Pandas in more depth.
Pandas is an open
source Python library
that provides easy to use, high
performance data structures
and data analysis tools.
Cuddly bears aside, the name
comes from the term panel data,
a common term for
multi-dimensional data
sets, encountered in both
statistics and econometrics.
To install Pandas, simply run
$ pip install pandas inside
your Python environment.
Then we can import pandas as pd.
One of the most common
things that Pandas ends up
being used for is
reading in CSV files
using the
[? read csv ?] function.
It is often the starting
point for using Pandas.
Pandas loads this
data into a DataFrame.
This can be thought of
as essentially a table
or a spreadsheet.
We can take a quick
glimpse of our data
by calling head on our
DataFrame DataFrames
have rows of data with
named columns, which
in Pandas are called series.
For me, one of the nicest
things about DataFrames
is the describe function, which
displays a table of statistics
about your DataFrame.
This is super useful for
sanity checking your data set,
seeing if the distribution of
your data looks reasonable,
and whether the properties are
what you expect them to be.
I also sometimes will use
Pandas to shuffle my data.
This can be useful
in situations where
you want to shuffle
the entire data set,
rather than merely
having a look ahead
buffer as you extract it out.
For example, if your data
is not shuffled at all,
and it is, in fact,
already sorted,
you'd want to give it
an extra good mixing.
However, for truly
huge data sets,
it's possible that this may
be impractical without more
sophisticated approaches.
To access a particular
column of a data set,
use bracket notation to pull
out that column, passing
in the name of that column.
If you're wondering what the
possible column names are,
you can look back at
the output of .describe,
or use df or dataframe.columns
to access all the columns
in the DataFrame as an array.
If you can access
data column by column,
then the next thing
you'll want to know
is how to access it by row.
Accessing rows of
DataFrames is a little bit
different than from columns.
For example, if we want the
row with an index i of a given
DataFrame, we can use iloc,
or i location, index location,
and i.
Keep in mind that Pandora
operates on a 0 based indexing
system.
So the first row is
actually index 0.
Sometimes you may want a
particular row and column.
Because rows and columns
are accessed differently,
we'll need different
techniques to get that done.
In particular, if you want
row 5 of a column called name,
you would use
something like this.
And where things get
much more interesting
is when you want to get a whole
range of columns and rows.
On the column side, the
way to get multiple columns
is to pass in an array
of those column names.
If there are many, many columns
and you don't want to type them
all out, you can use the columns
array, the .columns array,
and select a range of
column names from there,
and use that to select columns.
If we want to get
a range of rows,
we can use colon notation
inside the brackets
that follow iloc, like so.
And the starting index here
is included, while the ending
index is excluded.
So this will return row
indices 5, 6, 7, 8, and 9,
but not row index 10.
Say we wanted both--
both a subset of columns
and a subset of rows.
What would that look like?
Well, we can combine
what we've learned so far
and make one expression
that gets the job done.
So first we'll choose the column
names, just like we did before.
Then we get the columns
back, and then we
can select the rows from that
DataFrame using that colon
notation.
And so once you get
the hang of things,
you'll actually be able to
collapse these three lines down
into just one expression.
Something like this.
And if this is the
first time you're
seeing this sort
of collapsing, I'd
encourage you to
pause here and look
at how this expression is
exactly equivalent to what
we showed earlier.
I'll still be here
when you get back.
So happy to wait.
We've looked at some simple
data manipulation in this video,
and there is much more that
the Pandas ecosystem offers,
from its efficient file storage
in the form of pie tables
and HDF5 format to running
certain statistical analyzes.
Now this has been just a quick
overview of what Pandas can do,
so check out the
documentation links below
to start your
journey with Pandas.
Thanks for watching this
episode of Cloud AI Adventures.
Be sure to subscribe
to the channel
to check out future episodes
right when they come out.
For now, get out there and
try Pandas in the wild.